all right let's talk a little bit about
politicians then speaking of ratings and
the ability to get someone to tell the
truth they often I now see these
interview shows and politicians have a
way of no matter what you as the
interviewer ask they answer a completely
different question and and they
shamelessly do it how do you use or
directly honest get shunted aside when
it could be gold water and George
McGovern were two classic examples I've
interviewed them both many times and
both passed on now
Barry Goldwater on George McGovern had
no cut off between the brain in the
mouth
you guys no questions answered right
wiped out in national elections because
the public and the we in the media said
we want the wrecked honesty and then we
lambaste you if you directly honest so
what the politician tries to do is how
can I say something the best tip anybody
if you're watching an interview show
with a politician and a guest this ask
the question and the politician says I'm
glad you asked that
here's the truth he's solely not glad I
said and he has said I'm glad you asked
that so he can think of how to answer it
that will appeal to the largest common
denominator so I'm guessing you probably
heard that about four billion times in
25 years on CNN so you do the best you
can what I try to do is get at the core
of things I try to ask good questions
come around in a lot of ways but on the
other hand I have a great respect for
politicians for this reason they do
something that we don't do one they
stand up and be counted and they have
what we have never had in our lives they
have a Tuesday in November where the
score goes up and we don't do that oh we
have ratings but that's sporadic right
the score goes up so I've always
respected politicians and athletes
athletes have something we don't have
won their livelihood ends when most of
our really good livelihood begins the
cheering stops when they're 40 our rings
in life starts at 40
and number two they have a final score
you know ain't it you lost you know we
don't have a final score yeah I didn't
lose 4 to 3 today but somebody lost 4
somebody played basketball last night
and one team scored 102 and one team
scored 97 you can call all you want the
people on 97 lost they lost so is that
it right there is that the problem with
the media that we don't score things in
there is no respect at leats because
they face that yeah I respect
politicians because they get a Tuesday
in November that we don't have so I
begin with the respect for a man who ran
fro then I can
if he gets jaundiced or
off-the-beaten-track then you know you
tried it I you try to learn as much as
you can all I try to do in interviewing
was learn as much as I can when I yelled
at people I never learned anything